[Música]
hola a todos bienvenidos a este programa
especial de los observadores de France
24 que dedicamos a la crisis migratoria
en la frontera de Belarus y Polonia
contada por quienes la están grabando y
viviendo desde dentro muchos de ellos
están atrapados en medio de esta jujas
geopolítica y también muchos de ellos se
han puesto en contacto con nosotros
desde esta zona fronteriza ellos nos
contaron que las fuerzas de seguridad de
Belarus los estaban empujando hacia la
frontera algunos intentaron atravesar el
alambre de púas
pero los que lograron entrar a Polonia a
menudo son devueltos por los guardias
fronterizos a territorio de Belarus está
crisis comenzó este verano cuando ve la
luz en represalia por la censura de la
Unión Europea facilito la obtención de
visas a los ciudadanos de Irak y Siria
el objetivo era crear un movimiento
migratorio en las fronteras europeas
miles de hombres y mujeres creyeron así
poder aprovechar la oportunidad y
realizar su sueño de llegar a Europa
Mustafa moksin un estudiante de la
ciudad de Bagdad grabó todo su viaje
hoy no duermo en casa saben porque
viaje
voy a ponerlas en la maleta
no puedo dejarte ir
déjame ir adiós
vas a parar Lituania imposible hasta
dónde vas a ir hasta el final hasta
Alemania
recogemos nuestros tickets en agencia de
viajes tengo mi tiquete de avión Ibiza
espera por fin voy a salir de Irak
bye bye Irak
[Música]
Mustafa y sus amigos hacían parte de los
miles de posibles migrantes que llegaron
a Minsk la capital de Belarus muchos de
ellos viajaron en los vuelos de la
aerolínea estatal Belavia desde Estambul
Beirut o Dubai los migrantes de otras
partes del mundo incluida también África
también se enteraron de esta facilidad
para obtener las visas y comenzaron a
acudir en masa a Belarus cuando Mustafa
llegó el y sus amigos fueron recibidos
en el aeropuerto
de la mañana
[Música]
a quién ve la luz 100 $ son 246
esta es una tarjeta SIM internacional
funciona en cualquier país del mundo
nuestro conductor bielorruso nos ayuda
con la traducción
no llego al centro comercial compraremos
baterías externas y estaremos listos
para salir para los preparativos
necesarios el grupo acompañado de su
conductor se dirigió a la frontera el
trayecto desde Minsk hasta la frontera
polaca dura unas 4 horas 2 migrantes que
no tenían transporte propio podían tomar
taxis o autobuses hasta la zona
fronteriza los migrantes del Kurdistán
iraquí se organizaron y compartieron
varios vídeos información a través de
Facebook
les pedimos que compartan este vídeo
para la gente que no lo sabe hemos
indicado el lugar
mañana desde el mediodía hasta las 15
necesitamos que todo se reúnan forme un
gran grupo e iremos hacia la frontera
el vídeo con tenía la ubicación GPS de
esta estación de servicio en la
carretera M6 situada a solo 2 km de la
frontera con Polonia los migrantes
comenzaron a reunirse allí y a grabar
sus propios vídeos añadiendo algún tipo
de comentario o llamado para que otros
se unieran a es
esperamos que nadie sea rechazada
[Música]
hablamos con uno de los migrantes que
respondieron a este llamado
dónde se hizo Bloomberg el 8 de
noviembre temprano por la mañana salimos
hacia la frontera entre Belarus y
Polonia
tras varias horas de viaje en auto
llegamos al punto de encuentro Ortiz
Netflix
había entre 2000 y 2500 personas
cuando los guardias fronterizos de
Belarus les bloquearon el paso
el grupo se adentro en el bosque
acamparon a lo largo de la alambrada
[Aplausos]
ahora estamos en la frontera entre
Belarus y Polonia estamos atrapados
entre los guardias fronterizos
bielorruso detrás de nosotros y los
polacos delante
[Música]
hay gente de todas las edades
niños de 12 años bebés de 6 meses
debido al frío ya la falta de alimentos
estamos agotados la gente empieza a
tener frío y a enfermarse
[Música]
todos llegamos aquí con Visa cada
migrante en Belarus pago entre 6000 y
7000 $
traficantes de personas nos dijeron que
llegaríamos a Europa fácilmente y sin
peligro pero mintieron muy difícil
llegar a Europa aunque se intenté cruzar
la frontera varias veces todos son
rechazados y detenidos por la policía
en el lado de Belarus de la frontera las
fuerzas de seguridad suelen guiar a los
migrantes hay muchos testimonios que
evidencian que los guardias fronterizos
organizan el paso hacia Polonia a veces
incluso empujando a los migrantes a lo
largo de la alambrada nuestro observador
originario de un país africano intento
cruzar escoltado por las fuerzas de
seguridad bielorrusas pidió el anonimato
por su seguridad
así que cariño no subieron al camión
llegamos a la frontera de noche sobre
las 17 nos dijeron tienen que esperar
porque estamos esperando un buen momento
para pasar pero si los rusos se conocen
bien las fronteras polacas esos mismos
cortaron las barricadas nos hicieron
pasar y nos explicaron cómo avanzar
necesitábamos un GPS de todas formas nos
habían dicho no pueden quedarse aquí
tienen que avanzar dividirse en varios
grupos y nos dieron una ciudad
vayan a esta ciudad Sokolka cuando mire
el GPS eran al menos casi seis o siete
horas a pie
[Música]
había una excepción por cierto de la que
todos empezábamos a reírnos cuando
llegaban por la noche alrededor de la
una de la mañana decían gogogo podcast
[Música]
intento cruzar la frontera tres veces
pero en todos sus intentos fue capturado
por las fuerzas de seguridad por la casa
y devuelto al lado bielorruso sus hijos
empezaron a sentirse mal y finalmente se
rindio pero los guardias fronterizos no
lo dejaron salir de la zona de frontera
me dijeron aquí se entra y se avanza
solo hacia Polonia no se sale hacia
Veracruz los niños empezaron a tener
fiebre vimos al guardia fronterizo se
compadeció de nosotros pero nos pidió
dinero mi hija se enfermo así que no
tuve otra opción tenía que intentar al
menos a salvar una vida así que por mí
mi mujer y mis hijos para que en total
500 € hablamos con otros 2 migrantes que
desistieron de cruzar a Polonia y nos
confirmaron que les pagaron cientos de
euros a los guardias fronterizos
bielorruso para poder salir de la zona
fronteriza Mustafa y sus amigos llegaron
a la zona de frontera en auto y también
se encontraron con los guardias
fronterizos
el trayecto desde Minsk hasta la
frontera polaca dura unas 4 horas
allí en la frontera se bajaron del
vehículo y caminaron hasta la primera
alambrada
todavía no podemos cortar la al
principio oímos movimientos un soldado
bielorruso se acercó y nos dijo Go Go
los guardias por los golpearan el grupo
logro cruzar el cerco de al lado
bielorruso y luego de lado por la pero
fueron detenidos por los soldados de
Polonia y devueltos a la frontera nos
dieron una paliza si
el gato y el ratón
[Música]
Mustafa y sus amigos lograron cruzar la
frontera finalmente afirman que fueron
los guardias fronterizos quienes les
ayudaron a cortar y aplastar el
alambrado
hola
Ángeles tb
Mustafa logro llegar a Alemania y ahora
pública vídeos desde un centro de
tránsito de refugiados espera aprender
alemán y conseguir algún día un trabajo
en medios de comunicación
en noviembre hubo 100000 intentos de
cruzar la frontera polaca Mustafa es uno
de los pocos que ha podido llegar a
Europa Occidental mientras que otros
países como Irak han empezado a
organizar vuelos de repatriación los que
siguen en el lado bielorruso de la
frontera podrían verse obligados a
volver a casa seguiremos en contacto con
nuestros observadores en la frontera
entre Belarus y Polonia y les daremos
noticias sobre ellos a través de nuestro
sitio Web si quieren entrar en contacto
con la redacción del programa todos los
datos de contacto aparecen en sus
pantallas nos vemos en una próxima
edición de los observadores de France 24
hasta entonces